bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
comme tous les jeudis 10 questions
adressées au gouvernement avec cette
semaine comme thème bien sûr la sécurité
intérieure après la découverte cette
semaine dans le magasin printemps de
cinq packs d'explosifs
c'est michèle alliot marie la ministre
de l'intérieur qui répondra à cette
question est également une question
adressée à xavier darcos sur le
mouvement des lycéens des lycéens qui
défilent en ce moment même juste
derrière le sauna donc on y reviendra
sans doute tout à l'heure avec le
ministre de l'éducation direction tout
de suite l'hémicycle pour ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'ordre
appelle l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente et je compte sur chacun pour
respecter son temps la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre plancade pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue
merci monsieur les repas et monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
affaires étrangères la france reçoit en
ce moment à l'invitation de ce ministère
un représentant du hezbollah libanais
dans le cadre du programme d'accueil des
personnalités d'avenir personnalités
d'avenir cette invitation m'interroge
beaucoup
la france est elle obligée pour diallo
et d'inviter pendant plusieurs jours au
frais de l'état
un membre d'une organisation terroriste
alors que la france et les français ont
été victimes des axiomes cette
organisation peut-être monsieur le
ministre a obtenu des contreparties à la
main que vous tendez à ce membre du
hezbollah
par exemple l'application de la
résolution des nations unies demandant
le désarmement de cette organisation
peut-être au nom de la realpolitik dont
on a entendu parler récemment
considérez-vous déjà que le hezbollah
puisqu'il est question d'un programme
d'avenir sera demain le maître du liban
g et ce serait là une façon peut-être de
préserver l'avenir
j'ai bien conscience bien sûr de
l'avancée que constitue les accords de
doigts mais aussi de leur extrême
fragilité mais en tout cas ça ne
justifiait pas aujourd'hui en tout cas
une invitation d'état c'est pourquoi je
dirais que vous m'indiquer quelles
perspectives vous avez de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
quelle politique mène la france pour in
fine et protéger nos concitoyens de ce
fléau de cette menace quelqu'un soit
d'ailleurs l'origine qui paie chaque
jour un peu plus sur la paix et la
tranquillité du monde au répondre à
monsieur plancade la parole est à
monsieur à l'âge moyen des secrétaires
d'état chargé de la coopération et de la
francophonie vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur plancade je
comprends votre émotion
je tiens à vous préciser que cette série
d'invitations se passe non pas dans le
cadre de réception officielle mais au
contraire dans le cadre d'une démarche
diplomatique du ministère des affaires
étrangères qui vise à avoir des contacts
avec des personnalités en provenance de
tous pays pour se faire une idée des
circonstances politiques de ces états et
pourrait également conduire sa politique
d' influence ne voyez donc pas dans
cette réception une quelconque
reconnaissance
je comprends bien que le fait que ce
professeur d'université du liban et des
liens avec le hezbollah puisse susciter
la question que vous posez aujourd'hui
mais y compris avec le
hesbollah qui est lui-même présent je le
rappelle au sein du parlement y compris
avec le hezbollah la france a besoin
d'avoir des contacts
la france a besoin de savoir ce qui se
passe c'est la france a aussi besoin de
faire passer un certain nombre de
messages
on voit là le sens de ce programme
d'invitation des personnalités que l'on
qualifie d' avenir
s'agissant du hezbollah comprendrez que
ce n'est pas la position de la france
la france se veut avoir une diplomatie
universel pour pouvoir faire évoluer les
choses pour pouvoir faire évoluer le
monde il faut aussi parler avec tout le
monde
c'est ce que souhaite le président de la
république le gouvernement de françois
fillon c'est ce que nous faisons au
ministère des affaires étrangères ne
voyait pas d'autre signification que la
volonté de maintenir cette diplomatie
universel dans l'intérêt de la france
mais aussi dans l'intérêt de la paix et
du monde
la parole est à monsieur christian
gaudin pour le groupe union centriste
laver la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame le ministre
de l'intérieur la découverte mardi de
cinq bâtons de dynamite dans un magasin
parisien a ravivé la menace terroriste à
laquelle est confrontée notre pays
d'après ce que nous en savons il ne
s'agissait là que d'un avertissement
les explosifs en question était assortie
d'aucun dispositif de mise à feu et les
services de sécurité ont été avertis par
lunettes de revendications une bien ce
que curieuse lettre signée d'un groupe
apparemment jusqu'ici inconnu de vos
services
le front révolutionnaire afghans et
réclamant le départ des troupes
françaises d'afghanistan d'ici à la fin
de février 2009
depuis de nombreux spécialistes ont
semblé écarter la piste islamiste
madame la ministre vous avez annoncé que
l' enquête avance et vite
où en est elle disposez-vous d'éléments
nouveaux
plus généralement nous avons pu relever
quelques dissonances au sein du
gouvernement sur le degré de risque qui
pèse aujourd'hui sur le pays
la france est elle oui ou non
particulièrement exposées enfin nous
savons que suite à l'incident du
printemps haussmann
vous avez pris des mesures de
renforcement de la sécurité après avoir
vu hier les directeurs généraux de la
police et la gendarmerie le préfet de
police
les responsables des services de
renseignement des représentants la ratp
la sncf des aéroports de paris et des
grands magasins
pouvez vous préciser la nature de ces
mesures en particulier pour les quelques
jours qui nous séparent de noël pour
répondre à monsieur gaudin la parole est
à mme michèle alliot marie ministre de
l'intérieur de l'outre-mer des
collectivités territoriales vous avez la
parole madame le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises la france n'est pas
plus menacé que d'autres pays cela ne
veut pas dire qu'elle le soit moins
il faut donc être vigilant et cette
vigilance est assuré à la fois par nos
dispositifs éprouvé d'ailleurs de
sécurisation et par nos services de
renseignement cela implique d'ailleurs
aussi que nous sachions toujours nous
adapter en fonction du risque et c'est
ainsi que à la suite notamment des
attentats de bombay j'ai décidé d'un
exercice qui aura lieu lundi prochain
pour voir si nous sommes bien en mesure
de faire face par exemple à des prises
d'otages multiples qui aurait lieu dans
plusieurs villes à la fois ça se fera
lundi
en ce qui concerne l' alerte qui a eu
lieu dans les grands magasins où on a
découvert effectivement des bâtons de
dynamite je dirais du domaine civil ou
des travaux publics est relativement
anciens n'y avait pas de danger il faut
d'explosion vous l'avez dit pour autant
cela nous amène aussi à regarder ce
qu'il en est et à regarder ce que sont
nos dispositifs dans ce cas et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai immédiatement
que après cette découverte
de toute façon pris un certain nombre de
décisions
pour renforcer encore le dispositif que
j'avais mis en place à partir du 1er
décembre pour couvrir cette période
toujours extrêmement sensible et
notamment nous avons mis en place des
forces mobiles supplémentaires qui
viennent renforcer les patrouilles est
également mobilisé un certain nombre de
militaires dans le cadre du dispositif
vigipirate
en plus de ce qui existait la réunion
d'hier matin comme vous l'avez dit avec
les représentants des grands magasins de
la sncf de la ratp des aéroports de
paris nous a permis de faire le point et
surtout de mettre en place un nouveau
dispositif de suivi avec notamment trois
réunions par semaine entre ces
différentes personnalités à paris et
dans les grandes villes
et avec le préfet de police pour paris
et les préfets pour les régions la
décision également de renforcer un
certain nombre de contrôles dans les
grands magasins eux-mêmes notamment des
contrôles aléatoires sur les sacs de
faire en sorte également d'éloigner des
portes d entrée sensible les véhicules
qui pourraient aujourd'hui y stationner
qui représenterait un certain dispositif
est de renforcer encore les dispositifs
de contrôle avant l'ouverture des
magasins ou avant l'utilisation des pins
tout ceci est effectivement un ensemble
qui a une seule finalité assurer la
protection des français et surtout faire
en sorte que les français et les
touristes qui viennent puissent passer
des fêtes de noël faire leurs courses
avec une totale tranquillité d'esprit
comme le mérite cette période de l'année
merci madame la ministre
la parole est maintenant à monsieur jean
louis carrère pour le groupe socialiste
avait la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
elle concerne à la gendarmerie nationale
et sa présence sur nos territoires
donc elle intéresse la sécurité de tous
nos concitoyens
j'ai déjà discuté longtemps avec vous
madame le ministre de l'intérieur et je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de courtoisie
je connais vos réponses à ce sujet mais
il y a des choses que vous ignorez
peut-être
voilà pourquoi je m'adresse à monsieur
le premier ministre
voici une note issu de votre cabinet
monsieur le premier ministre
une note que certains qualifient faute
de pouvoir nier son existence de nul et
non avenu
or pour une note nul et non avenu elle
s'avère particulièrement pertinente
jugez vous même l annonce et prépare la
fermeture à partir de 2009 de 4 écoles
de gendarmerie sur huit
malgré les futile dénégations là le nom
tant question avait vu juste puisque il
y a quelques jours nous avons appris et
monsieur raffarin nous l'a confirmé que
effectivement quatre écoles seront
bientôt fermer or plus grave encore
toujours selon cette note que je vous
remets très monsieur le premier ministre
si vous ne l'avez pas vu serait prévu la
fermeture de 175 brigade territoriale
sur 1700 plus de 10% et aussi excusez du
peu
la suppression de 15 escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile sur 128
ma question chère amie est très simple
et elle intéresse tous les sénateurs sur
tous les bancs ce n'est plus une
question d'un groupe c'est une question
du sénat au gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez vous
nous assurez ici et maintenant qu'il n'y
aura pas de fermeture de brigade ni de
dissolution d'escadrons de gendarmerie
en 2009 ou alors
donnez nous la liste exacte et précise
des fermetures entraînée par la cure
d'amaigrissement à laquelle vous comptez
soumettre la gendarmerie tous les élus
de nos territoires attendent votre
réponse
pour répondre à monsieur jean louis
carrère vannes à michèle alliot marie
elise de l'intérieur de l'outre-mer et
des collectivités territoriales
monsieur carrère avec une courtoisie au
moins égale à la vôtre je vais vous
redire en présence du premier ministre
ce que je vous ai dit avant-hier hier et
même les fois précédentes
effectivement il y a eu et demain si
vous le souhaitez avait effectivement il
y à une note de travail fait en interne
par un membre du cabinet du premier
ministre qui devait servir de base de
travail
bien sûr qu'elle existe d'ailleurs vous
l'avez largement utilisé et d'une façon
vous me permettrez de vous le dire un
petit peu truqués 48 heures avant les
élections sénatoriales dans un certain
nombre d'endroits alors même que vous
saviez parfaitement puisque je l'avais
dit qu'il s'agissait d'une hypothèse de
travail qui ne tenait pas d'ailleurs la
preuve je vous l'a dit monsieur carrère
si vous permettez la preuve je vais vous
la dire parce que il faut pas donner
simplement des phrases la fermeture des
écoles de gendarmerie elle était prévue
depuis longtemps
en revanche cette note dont vous dites
qu'elle est la preuve qu'il y a des
choses
elle vous cite des écoles de gendarmerie
qui n'ont pas qui ne sont pas celles qui
ont été fermés donc c'est aussi la
preuve qu'il s'agit bien d'un document
de travail erronée et qui a été
contredit par la suite
et bien ce qui a été contredit sur les
écoles est également contredit sur les
fermetures de gendarmerie que vous
évoquez je vous ai dit et j'ai dit et
j'ai pris l'engagement devant la haute
assemblée
et vous savez que je n'ai pas l'habitude
de dire des choses erronées
j'ai dit effectivement que je tenais à
la présence de l'autorité de l'état et
donc des gendarmeries notamment dans les
zones les plus fragiles je vous ai dit
aussi au moment du budget qu'il y allait
avoir un recentrage sur le coeur de
métier des gendarmes ce qui nous permet
justement en les dégageant de tâches
administratives ou d'un certain nombre
de tâches indues de les mettre là où on
en a besoin c'est à dire dans les
brigades et qu'à partir de ce moment là
la présence de la gendarmerie
partout où cela est nécessaire et
notamment dans les zones rurales
continuerait elle continuera d'être
effectivement et d'être effectivement
réalisé parce que c'est bien là et j'en
suis consciente le sens et le besoin de
la protection de nos concitoyens
monsieur carrère ça n'est pas en
redisant dix fois des choses dont vous
savez pertinemment qu'elles sont fausses
qu'elles deviendront vrai merci madame
le ministre
la parole est maintenant un madame
brigitte gonthier maurin et à elles
seules monsieur mahias pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et des
sénateurs du parti de gauche avaient la
parole ma chère collègue monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur le ministre en septembre
dernier sur france 2 évoquant la réforme
du lycée vous invitiez les lycéens à
s'emparer du débat
ils vous ont semble-t-il prix au go à
tel point que leur mobilisation associée
à celle des enseignants des parents
d'élèves et plus largement à celle de la
de toute la communauté éducative vous
conduit à reculer sur la question du
lycée vous expliquer que cette réforme
serait l'otage d'un mouvement social
n'ayant pas grand chose à voir avec des
questions pédagogiques ce qui vous
inquiète justement c'est que peu à peu
se révèle la cohérence de la politique
conduite par le gouvernement
la déconstruction du service public dont
celui de l'éducation en est un maillon
comme l'est aussi celle du code du
travail
de fait une aspiration semble se
dessiner largement dans notre pays
cette aspiration c'est celle qui porte
l'exigence d'égalité et d'équité et donc
deux services publics vecteur d'un
véritable recul des inégalités cette
mobilisation prend de l'ampleur
à l'école elle s'exprime sous plusieurs
formes des manifestations fortes comme
aujourd'hui
réveillon revendicative dans des lycées
nuit blanche dans des écoles primaires
et fait inédit actions de désobéissance
des enseignants du primaire du primaire
des cas publiquement risque de sanction
leur refus d'appliquer votre réforme
contestation que la loi sur le service
minimum votée en urgence s'est testé n'a
pas fait taire loin dans mon groupe
défendra le 20 janvier
l'abrogation pour calmer l'inquiétude
vous annoncer par exemple un plan
national de formation des enseignants au
traitement de la difficulté
palliant la suppression de 3000 rased
mais avec quels moyens les crédits pour
la formation des enseignants baisse
budget après budget vous assurer que les
suppressions de postes n'affecte pas
l'encadrement pédagogique
comment expliquer alors aux parents qu'à
force de suppression de stagiaires c'est
la npa qui recrutent des cdd à 8 euros
71 de leurs pour assurer des
remplacements
monsieur le ministre il faut cesser la
caricature les enseignants les parents
d'élèves les lycéens ne refuse pas la
réforme
il refuse votre réforme parce qu'elle
est régressive pour l'école publique
à l'opposé les besoins éducatifs pour
assurer l'élévation du niveau de
connaissance et de formation pour tous
ces autres questions sur google alors
j'y arrive monsieur le président à ne
soyez pas impatients chers collègues
aussi monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple quand allez-vous repartir à
zéro et pas seulement pour le lycée pour
toute l'école
pour répandre la parole est un monsieur
xavier darcos ministre de l'éducation
nationale devait d'être en vie monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice d'abord
vous me demandez ce que nous devons
faire en ce qui concerne la réforme du
lycée je vais vous répondre très
clairement je vais répéter ce que j'ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois sans hésitation
nous allons reprendre les choses à zéro
nous allons ensemble rouvrir la totalité
du dossier
nous allons prendre le temps sans
hésiter précisément de sorte que l'on ne
dise pas que cette réforme est faite à
la va vite et pour des raisons qui ne
serait pas dictée par l'intérêt des
lycéens par l'intérêt des jeunes de ce
pays je voudrais d'ailleurs vous
rappeler quels en sont les principes
auxquels je reste très attaché et dont
je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs qu'il
puisse être discuté
faire en sorte que les lycéens et b je
vais vous le dire vous allez me dire
s'ils voulaient discuter monsieur naias
de le principe c'est que tous les
lycéens est une culture commune que nous
personnalise ion led led que nous devons
leur apporter que nous fassions en sorte
que ceux qui sont en difficulté plus de
soutiens qu'ils puissent avoir un second
choix s'ils se sont mis en très grande
difficulté par des options qu'ils
auraient mal choisi de sorte d'éviter
l'échec parce que quand on me dit que
nous faisons un système scolaire qui est
eux qui va être injuste écoutez
regardant la situation d'aujourd'hui est
ce qu'on va s'en satisfaire
pas plus tard qu'il ya deux jours pas
plus tard qu'il ya deux jours une
dernière statistique de l' ocde montré
que le système le plus injuste de tous
les pays développés de voeux de tous les
pays développés ci d'injuste c'est à
dire qui était le plus fixes liés aux
déterminants sociaux
c'était la france et je le regrette
aussi la république tchèque
c'est à dire que le milieu l'origine la
famille continue à jouer très fortement
sur le proto des pronostics scolaire ce
n'est pas du discrédit c'est précisément
la légitimation d'un système qui
s'adaptent mieux
aux élèves qui répondent à leurs besoins
donc je les dis ne reprendront à 0
j'observe d'ailleurs madame gonthier
maurin permettez moi de vous le rappeler
que les grands principes que je viens de
dire
ici ce sont des principes que nous
avions rédigé ensemble avec les
représentants des personnels et des
lycéens qui avait signé avec moi sur des
principes que je viens de donner ici et
que nous n'avons pas abandonné
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
circonstances nécessite plus
explications que nous travaillons
différemment nous allons le faire mais
nous ne changerons rien à l'objectif de
réforme parce que c'est évidemment
l'intérêt général qui nous dicte parce
que c'est le besoin de la nation et
parce que nous travaillons pour l'avenir
et mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
puisse dire une dernière chose
en m'adressant à des élus qui a intérêt
à faire en sorte que l'on confonde
l'inquiétude des lycéens le besoin de
parler avec eux et ce qui se passe ici
ou là dans nos quartiers et je regrette
qu'un certain d'élus à certains noms
d'élus et le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui défi d'électricien puisse
indirectement encouragé les débordements
que nous voyons aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'on défend la jeunesse et moi
je vous le dis dans quelques années
quand on fera le bilan
les jeunes lycéens verront de kiki du
gouvernement de françois fillon ou de
ceux qui défilent aujourd'hui ont
vraiment aimé la jeunesse merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
philippe dominati pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
messieurs les
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues donc quelques jours
prendra fin la présidence française de
la communauté européenne
cette présidence a été marquée par
l'autorité du président de la république
et nous sommes nombreux ici à avoir en
mémoire les événements des six derniers
mois où l'europe s'est exprimé d'une
manière unie et forte sur la scène
internationale
cela est dû au style personnel du
président de la république et cela a été
unanimement reconnue notamment à
strasbourg par des groupes
parlementaires et par les présidents des
assemblées
comment ne pas faire le bilan de cette
présidence six mois de présidence
si crise majeure six succès majeur pour
le diplomatie française tout d'abord la
résolution de trois crises de grande
amplitude une crise institutionnelle
suite au non irlandais qui débouchera
peut-être sur une solution avec
l'annoncé d'un second référendum
deuxièmement une crise militaire suite à
la crise russo géorgienne ou aujourd'hui
aux frontières de l'europe
alors qu'aujourd'hui cette crise semble
oubliée et enfin bien évidemment la
crise financière et économique qui
occupe l'attention de tout le
gouvernement et des gouvernements
mondiaux et des institutions financières
mondiales
enfin la résolution de trois dossiers
dits sensibles et majeur pour l'europe
l'union pour la méditerranée avec un
accord notamment entre les pays arabes
et l'état d'israël
un accord européen sur l'immigration
alors qu'on avait promis à d'autres
ministres de l'immigration un chemin un
parcours particulièrement difficile
et enfin il ya quelques jours un accord
sur le paquet énergie climat
alors que la conjoncture économique
laissait prévoir comme un probable un
accord de ce type pour des raisons
financières
alors le bilan monsieur le ministre
le bilan nous le connaissons et il est
flatteur et ce qui compte pour nous
c'est de connaître quelles sont les
perspectives pour la diplomatie
française pour contribuer pour
contribuer sur les impulsions qui ont
été donnés dans des dossiers majeurs
notamment dans le domaine de la
gouvernance économique une notion qui
n'existe est assez peu en europe il ya
six mois
dans la notion de la zone euro et de la
gestion particulière et spécifications
euro et également dans le domaine de la
défense commune
je vous remercie pour répondre un
philippe dominati la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il ya huit jours il y avait
ici un débat qui avait permis d'insister
sur le caractère extrêmement difficile
des dossiers qui étaient à l'ordre du
jour du dernier conseil européen et en
particulier chacun s'accordait à
reconnaître que la perspective de
trouver un accord sur la question de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
était une perspective très étroite tant
les positions des différents états
européens étaient éloignés je crois que
tout le monde peut se réjouir qu'après
un travail remarquable qui a été conduit
en particulier par jean louis borloo par
l'ensemble des équipes de la présidence
française soutenue par le parlement
européen dans une immense majorité nous
ayons pu réussir cet accord qui marquera
plus que tout le reste
la présidence française puisque non
seulement cet accord est historique
parce que c'est la première fois que des
grands pays développés se dote d'un
dispositif contraignant les engageant à
réduire de 20% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2020 et d'augmenter
de 20% les énergies renouvelables mais
surtout c'est un accord qui était vital
pour permettre la conclusion d'un grand
accord mondial à copenhague l'an
prochain nous ne savons pas si nous
réussirons
cette négociation de copenhague mais
nous savions en tout cas une chose c'est
que sans accord à bruxelles la semaine
dernière il n'y avait aucune chance de
réussir un accord sur le climat à
copenhague et je voudrais faire
remarquer que l'accord qui a été négocié
à bruxelles a été soutenue par plus de
600 députés européens sur 700 et en
particulier par le groupe du ppe par le
groupe socialiste par une grande partie
du groupe des verts au parlement
européen c'est dire si tout le monde
s'est accordé à reconnaître que le
compromis qui avait été trouvée était un
compromis satisfaisant
deuxièmement nous étions fixé un
objectif qui était de rouvrir même si
c'est très difficile
la voie de la ratification en
particulier par l'irlande du traité de
lisbonne
cette voie est ouverte maintenant c'est
évidemment au peuple irlandais qu'il
appartient de prendre ses
responsabilités mais nous avons réussi à
convaincre l'ensemble des états
européens de faire un certain nombre de
concessions qui permettent aujourd'hui
la réouverture de ce débat nous nous
étions fixés des objectifs ambitieux en
matière de politique de défense
c'est un des sujets les plus difficiles
parce que nous savons qu'il n'ya pas sur
cette question une grande identité de
vues en europe et qu'il n'y a surtout
pas chez beaucoup de pays européens une
grande volonté de fer nous avons obtenu
deux avancées importantes la première
c'est un engagement à l'unanimité des
états l'union européenne d'augmenter les
capacités globales de défense de l'union
et le deuxième c'est une un engagement
de la part des principaux pays
producteurs de force de mettre en oeuvre
une force d'intervention européenne de
60 mille hommes et c'est évidemment loin
des objectifs auxquels les plus
ambitieux des pays européens rêve mais
c'est ce que nous allons essayer de
réaliser enfin nous avons obtenu à
l'unanimité le pacte commun sur
l'immigration ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des pays
européens à l'unanimité a reconnu le
bien fondé du
tess française qui est la thèse de
l'immigration choisie au service d'une
intégration réussie
enfin nous avons adopté un plan de
relance de 200 milliards d'euros
un plan de relance de 200 milliards
d'euros qui valide le plan de relance du
gouvernement français puisqu'il est tout
entier tourné sur l'investissement et
sur la nécessité des réformes de
structure voilà mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le bilan de cette
présidence française je voudrais rendre
hommage à hubert haenel qui pour le
sénat au nom de la délégation a joué un
rôle considérable et vous dire enfin que
nous avons fait la démonstration que les
problèmes de l'europe n'étaient pas
seulement des problèmes institutionnels
mais c'était surtout des problèmes de
volonté politique
enfin je voudrais dire à monsieur
carrère que le gouvernement s'exprime
comme il l'entend et que vous pourriez
montrer l'exemple de la politesse du
respect des autres et de l'ecoute de la
démocratie merci monsieur le premier
ministre c'est le président qui préside
monsieur carrère la parole est à
monsieur rené pierre signé pour le
groupe socialiste avait la parole
oui monsieur le président deux minutes
et demie quelles questions que je posais
âgeuse est posée à madame la ministre
madame bachelot à propos des conditions
de travail des médecins urgentistes
l'association des médecins urgentistes
qui s'appelle la muse a appelé le 17
novembre dernier les praticiens à
arrêter le travail à partir du 1er
décembre
il s'agit d'une grève symbolique sans
impact sur la prise en charge des
malades des médecins assurant un service
minimum en cas de besoin les urgentistes
protestent contre une autre forte
augmentation de l'horaire de travail
quand les restrictions budgétaires
contre les suppressions de postes
l'annnonce de 20000 emplois supprimés
dans les hôpitaux des inquiète
et quand on les fermetures de services
notamment des services d'urgence samu et
smur
ils demandent la reconnaissance du temps
de travail et la valorisation de ce
temps à partir de la 39e heures à noter
qu'ils travaillent souvent plus de 70
heures consécutives et qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un travail de routine il
simplement technique mais d'une tâche
épuisante à hautes responsabilités et
surtout d'une tâche humaine or les liens
à tisser médecin malade
pourtant si nécessaire sont oubliées
gommé par la rigueur de la tarification
à l'activité
c'est la déshumanisation progressive
d'un métier qui fonctionne pourtant pour
partie sur le monde affectif le
ministère de la santé affirme que ce
sont les urgences qui ont bénéficié
depuis dix ans du plus grand nombre de
moyens au sein de l'hôpital
ce que conteste la muse pour ce qui
concerne les urgentistes
d'ailleurs les services d'urgence n'ont
connu qu'une faible progression en
nombre d'intervenants alors qu'ils sont
de jour en jour plus encombré puisqu'ils
arrivent aux urgences
toute personne qui ne peut bénéficier
d'un médecine libérale
trop d'erreurs et d'accès difficile
on touche du doigt en matière de
politique sanitaire et hospitalière la
myopie de la politique gouvernementale
qui ne voient pas ou ne veut pas voir la
dégradation inquiétante d'un système de
santé la france qui s'énorgueillit de
son exemple la protection sociale de ses
performances des performances de sa
médecine doit réviser ce jugement et sur
la célérité du traitement d'urgence et
sur la protection sociale
amputé d'année en année et sur la
sécurité sanitaire qui n'est plus
assurée dans les zones rurales
sinon par les sapeurs pompiers la grève
dans les services largement suivi est
approuvée par une forte majorité de
l'opinion
elle reçoit aussi le soutien d'une large
intersyndicale et sera suivie d'une
grande journée de mobilisation pour la
défense de l'hôpital public
ce sera le résultat probant de
l'exaspération entre les salaires des
médecins plus largement du personnel
hospitalier ne voulons plus travailler
dans des conditions qui se dégrade de
jour en jour et ne permettent plus
d'assurer la sécurité des patients
ce sera aussi la sourde expression des
craintes regret sio les trois financier
sepa va bientôt atteindre les limites du
supportable
ils sont accablés des hôpitaux par un
déficit déjà très lourd
si la désorganisation des services
d'urgence s'ajoute à cette 3025 mauvais
coup supplémentaire porté aux services
publics
ma question est donc simple la
dégradation des services de soin
hospitalier en particulier des services
d'urgence
est elle vraiment perçu les malades et
les médecins urgentistes peuvent dit
n'attendre une amélioration du
fonctionnement de ses services pour
répondre la parole à madame roselyne
bachelot narquin il de la santé de la
jeunesse des sports monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur signé vous avez tort de
répercuter les slogans d'une
organisation qui n'est pas
représentative et qui est précisément
désavoué par les quatre organisations
inter syndicale
représentative des praticiens
hospitaliers qu'en est il des services
d'urgence dans notre pays
nous sortons de trois ans d'efforts
intenses en service des urgences pour
les services d urgence qui nous ont
permis de créer 5000 200 postes dans les
services d'urgences et de créer 7500
lits contrairement ce que vous dites
le nombre des services d'urgence n'a
cessé d'augmenter dans notre pays pour
être fixé 147
c'est ainsi par exemple que dans votre
département monsieur le sénateur signé
j'ai créé cette année une antenne de ce
mur héliporté à clamecy donc laisse
nombre de services d'urgence ne cesse
d'augmenter alors même que la situation
des services d'urgence voient les
entrées constamment augmenté elles ont
doublé en 15 ans et nous savons très
bien que 80% des accueils des passages
en services d'urgence pourraient être
traitées d'une autre façon
qu'allons-nous donc faire dans ce
domaine nous allons agir sur plusieurs
leviers d'abord en amont des services
d'urgence pour résoudre les problèmes de
démographie médicale permettre une
meilleure permanence des soins et nous
aurons l'occasion d'en débattre ici dans
quelques semaines lors de la loi hôpital
patients santé territoires agir
également sur laval pour permettre une
meilleure un meilleur accueil des
personnes âgées avoir un meilleur lien
hôpital accueille des personnes âgées
accueillent des personnes handicapées
mais nous allons continuer nos
rénovations de services d'urgence à
travers la loi à travers le plan de
financement hôpital 2012
nous avons aussi des missions d'appui à
l'organisation savez vous par exemple
qu'à l'hôpital ambroise paré de boulogne
donc très près très près d'ici grâce à
la réorganisation nous avons pu diminuer
de 25 % le temps d'accueil des personnes
âgées diminué de 50% les hospitalisation
de courte durée
qui suivent l'admission en urgence et
réduire à zéro le temps d'urgence pour
les urgences véritablement constaté nous
allons donc la possibilité d'agir sur
plusieurs leviers
je vais d'ailleurs recevoir la semaine
prochaine à certains nombres
d'urgentistes j'installe le conseil
national de l'urgence dans les premiers
jours dans les premiers jours de janvier
nous écoutons les urgentistes et nous
voulons avoir dans notre pays des
services d'urgence performant c'est ce
que nous faisons
merci madame la ministre cas par an
l'état madame joëlle garriaud-maylam
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
vous avez la parole majeur collègues si
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le secrétaire
d'état alain joyandet
monsieur le ministre voilà déjà une
trentaine d'années que la communauté
internationale a fait le constat de
l'inégalité croissante entre hommes et
femmes
ce constat est d'autant plus pertinent
est alarmant dans les pays du sud
notamment en afrique pour ne citer que
quelques chiffres les femmes africaines
ne perçoivent que 10 % des richesses 2%
des crédits ch
alors qu et 5% des terres alors qu'elle
effectue plus de 66% du travail et
qu'elles produisent plus de la moitié
des richesses nationales vos
universitaire rapports internationaux
ont démontré que la réduction des
inégalités hommes femmes est un vecteur
indispensable pour le développement et
la croissance
la coopération française de pas son
action sectorielle et géographique
a les moyens d'agir dans ce domaine sur
le terrain et je rappellerai que nous
avons beaucoup de françaises et de
français qui sont engagés aux quatre
coins du monde sur ces questions de
coopération avec beaucoup de talent et
de détermination
avec son expertise projet la france doit
promouvoir les femmes comme vecteur
comme actrices du développement et je
pense notamment à l'octroi de
micro-crédits et surtout aussi à
l'éducation des enfants et des jeunes
filles en particulier comme ceci est
d'autant plus important que la france
vous le savez est porteuse de valeurs en
ce sens il est signataire d'engagements
internationaux extrêmement importants
comme les huit objectifs millénaire pour
le développement alors monsieur le
secrétaire d'état monsieur le ministre
en prenant vos fonctions vous avez
souhaité placer l'égalité des sexes et
l'autonomie ni l'autonomisation des
femmes pardonnez-moi au coeur de votre
action aussi je souhaiterais connaître
les mesures que vous avez prises et
celles que vous comptez prendre en ce
sens pour répondre à madame
garriaud-maylam la parole est à monsieur
alain joyandet secrétaire d'état chargé
de la coopération et la francophonie
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice d'abord permettez
moi de vous remercier pour votre
implication personnelle dans la cause
que vous défendez
je veux dire à cette occasion qu' il est
bon que nous nous posions la question de
la solidarité en direction des pays du
sud dans cette crise internationale nous
parlons beaucoup des questions de
politique intérieure le président de la
république nicolas sarkozy a réaffirmé à
doha que les pays du sud ne devait pas
être les victimes
plus encore que les autres de cette
crise financière s'agissant de la
question plus précise que vous posez le
premier ministre françois fillon a
souhaité justement pour que nous tenions
nos engagements que les questions du
genre soit traité correctement ou c'est
notre politique de coopération
nous allons donc
consacré 20 millions d'euros
spécifiquement dédié à la question du
genre et la position des femmes
notamment dans la société africaine
comment ne pas penser dans les
nombreuses visites que j'ai effectuée à
ces femmes notamment à qui mme berra
vous êtes allés aussi je crois à côté de
nairobi dans cet immense bidonville de
800000 personnes ou ces femmes
africaines merveilleuse tiennent la
société à bras le corps et notamment en
oeuvrant au sein des politiques
agricoles l'agriculture urbaine et bien
ce sont toutes ces opérations
spécifiques que nous allons financer
adam la sénatrice il y aura dans toutes
les politiques de coopération une
connotation genre une connotation femmes
deux projets majeurs à titre d'exemple
vont être soutenus
la maternité de kaboul les opérations
d'assainissement qui sont tenus par les
femmes notamment au burkina faso chaque
ambassade 30 ambassades au minimum
notamment en afrique auront à leur
disposition une enveloppe spécifique
pour répondre à un appel à projet qui
verra au coeur de la réalisation de ces
projets le rôle des femmes les femmes et
notamment en afrique subsaharienne
tiennent la société elles sont victimes
et en même temps elles sont très
valeureuse 90% des micro crédits sont
mises en oeuvre par les femmes
sachez que 95% des mensualités de ces
micro-crédits sont assurées tout à fait
normalement
il ya donc eu effectivement vous avez
raison d'avoir de porter une attention
toute particulière dans nos politiques
de développement
c'est la volonté du gouvernement c'est
ce que nous faisons et c'est ce que j'ai
annoncé ce matin avec des actions très
concrètes pour aller dans ce sens et ne
jamais oublier que l'avenir du continent
africain en ce moment même au moment où
nous parlons passe par les femmes
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur jean desessard pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés et rattachés
il avait la parole monsieur deux et ça
ma question s'adresse à monsieur brice
hortefeux ministre de l'immigration
elle concerne la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers et plus
particulièrement les 88 travailleurs
intérimaires sans papiers qui sont en
grève
active depuis le 3 juillet dernier
devant l' agence d'intérim qui les
emploie
man btp dans le 10e arrondissement de
paris tout d'abord monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie de votre réponse rapide
à mallette du 11 décembre dernier où je
demandais qu'une solution soit trouvée
avant la fin de l'année mais malgré tout
le contenu de votre réponse reste
insuffisant au regard de l'urgence de la
situation dans laquelle se trouvent ces
travailleurs je crois utile que l'on
change d'autres regards vis-à-vis des
travailleurs migrants
en effet où est le scandale ou et
l'inacceptable monsieur ministre est ce
le fait que ces personnes soient venues
en france pour travailler et nourrir
leurs familles ou bien est-ce
l'existence de réseaux clandestins d'un
marché de travail
underground qui profitent de la
situation de ces travailleurs sans
papiers où est le scandale ou l
inacceptable monsieur le ministre vient
il de ces travailleurs sans frontières
qui abandonnent leur pays pour venir
construire nos routes nos écoles et nos
hôpitaux ou bien des boursicoteurs sans
frontières qui spéculent et
s'enrichissent sans rien produire pour
la société alors cessé de les considérer
ces travailleurs sans papiers comme des
délinquants et regarder leur mouvement
de grève comme celui de salariés comme
les autres qui se battent pour la
reconnaissance et le respect de leurs
droits
ce combat nous concerne tous car il
s'agit de lutter contre le travail au
noir et l'exploitation de la
clandestinité par exemple pour les
travaux pour les travaux illégaux tels
le traitement de l'amiante sans prix
sans protection les critères que vous
avez mis en place monsieur le ministre
pour apporter une solution aux
mouvements sociaux des travailleurs sans
papiers ont permis de régulariser plus
d'un milieu plus d'un millier de ces
travailleurs
un millier mais ces critères ne
correspondent pas à la situation
spécifique des intérimaires pourtant ces
hommes travaillent en france depuis
plusieurs années
certains depuis plus de huit ans ils
sont très appréciés des chefs d'equipe
qui reconnaissent la qualité de leur
travail et leur savoir faire et les
rappels qui ces chefs d'équipé rappelle
régulièrement car elles ont besoin d'eux
sur les chantiers d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
la totalité de ces 88 salariés
intérimaires ont des promesses
d'embauché de vinci eiffage et rabot
dutilleul et de l'entreprise d'intérim
man btp alors ma question est simple sur
le ministre êtes vous prêt à régler la
région à régulariser la situation de ces
travailleurs intérimaires avant la fin
de l'année ce serait un geste du
gouvernement qui prouverait ainsi que
l'urgence est bien la lutte contre le
travail clandestin et non à la
répression des sans papiers qui ont osé
porter au grand jour leur situation pour
répondre la parole est à monsieur brice
hortefeux ministre de l'immigration de
l'intégration de l'identité nationale et
du développement solidaire on avait la
parole bien monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean desessard
merci d'abord d'avoir souligné que vous
m'aviez écrit et que je vous ai répondu
sur le fond pas sur la forme pas un exil
réception sur le fond et en moins de six
jours
vous savez le gouvernement avance sur ce
sujet complexe difficile avec un
principe simple lisible clair je pense
compréhensible c'est qu' un étranger en
situation irrégulière a vocation à être
reconduit dans son pays d'origine sauf
sauf situation humanitaire sanitaires
économiques et sociales et très
concrètement cela signifie que sur la
base de l'article 40 de la loi de
novembre 2007 je crois pas vous faire
injure aux yeux vous l'avez assez
mollement soutenu mais sur la base de
cet article il est possible procéder à
des régularisations
selon des critères là aussi de
travailleurs et irrégulier selon les
critères qui sont assis là aussi
compréhensible premièrement il faut
fournir un vrai contrat de travail que
j'avais fait allusion
deuxième élément il faut que ce contrat
de travail porte sur une activité qui
soit un métier sous tension c'est-à-dire
dans lequel il ya des difficultés de
recrutement et enfin naturellement il
faut que l'entreprise s'engage à
acquitter les taxes qui sont dues
lorsque l'on recrute comme vous savez un
travailleur étranger et vous le voyez
vous avez évoqué l'importance de ce
phénomène
souvenez vous on nous avait annoncé de
50 voire 100 mille dépôt de dossier il y
en a eu en tout et pour tout trois mille
cinq cents 3500
on aboutit à un examen individuel au cas
par cas qui a permis la régularisation
grosso modo 2000 un peu plus de 1000
travailleurs clandestins alors sur la
situation des intérimaires vous avez
raison c'est une situation particulière
qui mérite une attention particulière
qu'est ce que l'on peut dire sur ce
sujet premièrement ce que l'on peut dire
c'est qu'il n'est pas question je vous
le dis je c'est intéressant serait très
dangereux de régulariser tous ceux qui
sont dans le secteur de l'intérim
parce que certains d'entre eux comme
vous le savez travaillant était
simplement quelques heures et donc ya
pas de perspective d'intégration en
revanche et là vous avez raison il faut
se pencher sur ce qu'ils ont de réelles
capacités et perspectives d'intégration
je pense à ceux qui bénéficient d'un
contrat de mission qui peut être de 12
mois ou des entreprises qui s'engagent à
fournir un volume de travail c'est
d'ailleurs ce à quoi vous faites
allusion
un volume de travail qui pourrait être
l'équivalent d'un smic par mois
donc ça ça permet effectivement une
régularisation mais je vous le dis
simplement faites attention parce que si
vous prenez l'opinion à témoin vous
essayé de la prendre sur des bons
critères
moi je vous citerai simplement deux
enquêtes d'opinion
la première montre elle est par sap a
elle été publié dans le parisien et
aujourd'hui en france que 68% des
français approuvent l'examen des
situations au cas par cas et la seconde
qui est sorti qui est sorti il ya
quelques jours vous l'avez péter lui en
tout cas plutôt pour les franciliens
cédant journal métro montre que 83% 83 %
de nos compatriotes considèrent que la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
doit être prioritaire ou est
indispensable selon les catégories
ça signifie tout simplement que le
gouvernement je vous dis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs répond à ses
attentes
en s'appuyant sur une méthode qui
essaient de la concertation est un
principe est celui de la justice mme
merci
merci monsieur le ministre a parlé
maintenant monsieur jacques gauthier
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
vous avez la parole l'ancien premier
ministre madame messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame michèle alliot marie
ministre de l'intérieur de l'outre-mer
et des collectivités territoriales
madame le ministre les médias et mes
collègues tout à l'heure ont largement
évoqué la menace d'attentât qui a pesé
sur un grand magasin parisien et sur les
mesures que vous avez prises
immédiatement pour renforcer la présence
policière pendant les fêtes notamment
dans les lieux commerciaux dans les
gares et les aéroports
et je crois qu'il faut bien préciser que
c'est un volet important et essentiel de
votre action mais nos concitoyens
s'intéresse aussi et je dirais presque
surtout à la délinquance quotidienne
dans leur environnement immédiat
celle qui ne fait pas forcément la une
des journaux mais à laquelle nous
représentants des territoires
nous sommes très attachés dans nos
communes dans le département et de
région
je crois savoir même le mini ce que vous
venez d'enregistrer de bons résultats
dans ce domaine et que vous avez atteint
en 18 mois
les objectifs chiffrés ambitieux que
vous avez fixé le prix dans la
république pour la période de deux ans
nous constatons d'ailleurs sur le
terrain une amélioration sensible
alors madame le ministre avec quelques
jours d'avancé
accepteriez-vous de dresser un bilan de
votre action dans ce domaine et aussi de
préciser les axes de votre politique
pour le futur et puis en concluant
madame le ministre permettez moi de vous
remercier de vous remercier de votre
engagement personnel en direction des
forces de sécurité mais aussi de nos
concitoyens
on répondra monsieur jacques gauthier la
parole et à madame michèle alliot marie
ministre de l'intérieur de l'outre-mer
et des collectivités territoriales
vous avez la parole à la ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
il est vrai que après déjà des résultats
sensible enregistrée entre 2002 et 2007
grâce à l'action des forces de l'ordre
des policiers et des gendarmes au
quotidien sur notre territoire
la délinquance a connu de nouveaux
reculs significatifs
en effet en l'espace de 18 mois
nous avons noté un recul de la
délinquance de plus de la délinquance de
proximité par don de plus de 12% de
pardon de près de 12% 11,7 exactement
pour un objectif qui était fixé à 10%
nous avons donc effectivement que obtenu
une baisse très sensible en ce qui
compte
cela représente surtout parce que les
pourcentages c'est une chose mais je
veux surtout le dire que cela représente
de l'ordre de 130 mille victimes de
moins c'est ça ce qu'il faut retenir
comme chiffres en ce qui concerne la
délinquance générale de la même façon il
y à une accélération de la baisse de
cette délinquance nous en sommes
aujourd'hui à plus de 4,2 pour cent pour
un objectif qui était de 2 4%
et puis nous avons également et je crois
que c'est important de le souligner des
taux d'élucidation des crimes des délits
qui sont extrêmement important parce que
l'élucidation c'est finalement la
première justice qui est rendue à une
victime savoir que la police ou la
gendarmerie a arrêté celui qui lui a
commis à qui a commis un délit
et bien c'est quelque chose d'important
et sur les taux d'élucidation nous
sommes effectivement à près de 38% pour
un objectif de 40% et avec une
accélération au cours de ces derniers
mois je n'aurai pas la cruauté de
rappeler que nous en étions à 21% en
2001 c'est à dire que nous avons fait
plus que doubler cela sain c'est dû
effectivement à l'action de la police et
de la gendarmerie
et que certaines mesures ne sont pas non
plus étrangère à cela notamment le
recentrage des gir sûr je dirais ce qui
était le fondement même de leur travail
c'est à dire essentiellement sur la
lutte contre l'économie souterraine et
la lutte contre la drogue qui dans un
certain nombre de quartiers est à
l'origine de nombreux actes de
délinquance la création également des
unités territoriales de quartier dans
des endroits les plus sensibles et des
compagnies de sécurisation
je crois que ce sont là des éléments qui
ont contribué à ces excellents chiffres
alors bien entendu nous allons continuer
à élargir l'action notamment des unités
territoriales de quartier des compagnies
de sécurisation à de nouveaux lieux il y
aura un déploiement important au cours
de l'année 2009 et puis c'est également
tout le développement de la police
technique et scientifique qui a un rôle
essentiel en matière d'élucidation
ce sera également le développement des
caméras et de la vidéo protection qui
étaient treize ans dessous de la moyenne
des autres pays aux coûts dans notre
propre pays
eh bien à partir de là effectivement
nous allons donner les moyens aux
policiers et aux gendarmes dont la
détermination et le courage au quotidien
ont permis ces chiffres de faire plus et
mieux encore et ce seront notamment les
moyens qui sont inscrits dans la loppsi
dont je ne doute pas qu'elle sera
approuvée à l'unanimité
n'est ce pas puisque messieurs au delà
des récriminations
ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est les
résultats je vous ai rappelé quels
étaient les ventes pas quelles étaient
les vôtres
je suis heureuse de dire aujourd'hui
messieurs et mesdames de la majorité
quels sont les vôtres
mais si le ministre en est maintenant à
nous est sophie joissains pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
il avait la parole madame merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur xavier
darcos ministre délégué de l'éducation
nationale elle sera brève
monsieur le ministre vous avez récemment
affirmé devant notre assemblée que vos
propos sur la maternelle avaient été
volontairement sortis de leur contexte
et ce pour leur faire dire linverse ce
que vous aviez effectivement déclaré je
connais votre attachement à l'école
maternelle et votre respect de ceux qui
enseignent
mais malgré les précisions que vous avez
apporté je constate chaque jour dans mon
département
l'ampleur des craintes suscitées par
cette entreprise d information parmi ces
craintes
figurent notamment l'idée que vous
voudriez supprimer une partie de la
maternelle en réduisant d'une année le
cycle des apprentissages premiers dons
veut des pourtant décrire le programme
monsieur le ministre
ma question sera très simple pouvez vous
nous dire quelle place vous accordez à
l'école maternelle dans votre réforme de
l'école primaire et quels sont vos
projets pour l'école maternelle comme la
sénatrice
la parole est maintenant à monsieur et
xavier darcos ministre de l'éducation
nationale avait la parole jemini
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice joissains moi je comprends
l'émotion des familles et du monde
éducatif
lorsqu'avec une vidéo tronquée on fait
dire aux médications nationale qui veut
supprimer les maternelles et lorsqu'on
lui fait dire le contraire de ce qu'il
dit au point de faire croire que bien
qu'il ait été élu pendant près de vingt
ans qu'ils soient père et grand père et
qu'il ait été élu dans des secteurs
précisément qui lui permet de s'occuper
d'éducation
il imagine que des professeurs d'école
maternelle soit des puéricultrices
mais cette manière de déformer mes
propos je le répète n'a été utilisé qu'à
des fins politiques personne doute une
seconde comme ministre de l'éducation
nationale personne ne doute une seconde
que ministre de l'éducation nationale
soit attaché aussi que le premier soit
attaché à l'école maternelle qui
accueille tous les enfants de france
d'une manière systématique pour leur
offrir les enseignements des deux ont
besoin
il n'y a aucune menace d'aucune sorte
d'école maternelle et à d'ailleurs si
peu madame joissains que aujourd'hui
même
j'ai reçu l'association générale des
enseignants des écoles et des classes
maternelles la gemme etc avec eux tout à
l'heure nous avons signé un accord une
déclaration commune sur la manière de
sauvegarder l'essentiel de ce qui se
passe rien école maternelle nous sommes
mis d'accord sur un pilotage pédagogique
meilleur à partir d'un paul qui sera
départementalisée de sorte que partout
on puisse veiller au bon fonctionnement
des codes maternelle et que en aucune
manière des parents ne puisse ne pas
accéder à ce service
un plan national de formation qui va
être mise en place pour les professeurs
d'école maternelle en particulier pour
ceux qui entrent dans le métier et ceux
qui veulent continuer à se former dans
le domaine du langage des jeux de la
formation et puis enfin des documents
pédagogiques qui accompagneront
l'ensemble de ce projet que nous
élaborons en partenariat précisément
avec la science cherchons générale des
enseignants des écoles et des classes
maternelles et puis nous éditerons un
guide pour les parents qui a d'ailleurs
été réduit en grande partie par la gm
aussi qui sera diffusé partout
voilà mesdames et messieurs une fois de
plus je le dis comment se fait-il dans
ce pays qu'on ne puisse pas sur les
questions scolaires par les froidement
et qu'il faille insulté à la raison en
faisant croire que mini ce deal
contraire de ce qu'il dit lorsque on a
tout simplement à s'occuper de l'avenir
des enfants de france je regrette ces
méthodes
et bien je vais vous dire ce que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure en recevant la gemme
il avait rédigé une motion en faveur de
l'école maternelle qui circulait car
aussi beaucoup de signatures
elles viennent recevoir la mienne aussi
merci
monsieur le ministre nous aurons fini
mes chers collègues des questions
d'actualité devrait remercier madame
anne marie payet et monsieur guérini et
deux secrétaires qui sont à mes côtés je
vais maintenant suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise dans quelques minutes pour
la suite de l'examen du projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2008
la séance est suspendue
voilà vous venez donc de suivre en
direct sur notre antenne ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec
notamment cette dernière question à
laquelle a répondu xavier darcos le
ministre de l'éducation de questions
aujourd'hui pour le ministre a et alors
que se déroule une manifestation des
lycéens des professeurs aux alentours du
jardin du jardin du luxembourg c'est à
dire autour du sénat xavier darcos qui a
déclaré qu'il allait reprendre sa
réforme à la base pour revoir notamment
avec les syndicats les fondamentaux de
cette réforme le ministre de l'éducation
qui a également accusé la gauche de
souffler sur les braises et peut-être
d'un site et par là même les jeunes à
des débordements en marge de ces
manifestations de lycéens
on va voir s'illuminer de l'éducation
xavier darcos accepte de répondre dans
quelques instants à nos questions et
donc de revenir un petit peu sur les
déclarations qu'il a faites aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle du sénat
parmi les autres interventions des
ministres cet après midi il y avait bien
sûr la mise de l'intérieur michèle
alliot marie qui a répondu à une
question sur la sécurité intérieure
après cette menace d'attentât dans le
grand magasin le printemps à paris elle
a bien sûr tenu à rassurer les
parlementaires et par là même les
français sur les mesures de sécurité
prises aux abords des grands magasins
pendant cette période de noël ou bien
sûr les français ont besoin de faire
leurs courses en toute sécurité et en
toute sérénité
et puis dans
les autres questions qui ont aussi été
abordés il ya eu une interpellation du
sénateur socialiste jean louis carrère
sur la carte territoriale de la
gendarmerie
vous le savez peut-être la réforme de la
gendarmerie a été adoptée cette semaine
par le sénat et par là même adopté
définitivement par le parlement
donc la gendarmerie qui va rejoindre la
police et qui va être gérée
définitivement par le ministère de
l'intérieur une refonte de
l'organisation de la gendarmerie qui ne
plaît pas à tous les parlementaires et
notamment pas à tous les sénateurs de
gauche c'est pour ça que jean louis
carrère interpellé aujourd'hui donc la
ministre de l'intérieur michèle alliot
marie qui va désormais piloter la
gendarmerie ch
françois fillon est également intervenu
dans l'hémicycle tout à l'heure il est
revenu sur le bilan de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
il s'est notamment félicité de
l'intervention mardi dernier du
prétendant république devant le
parlement européen
voilà notre premier invité cet après
midi c'est le ministre de l'immigration
brice hortefeux il répond aux questions
de emmanuel kessler
oui je suis avec le ministre brice
hortefeux ministre chargé de
l'immigration et de l'intégration
également monsieur le ministre avant
d'en venir
à la question qui vous a été posée tout
à l'heure tous nomme une question sur la
situation politique générale on a le
sentiment que cette avant la trêve des
confiseurs c'est un petit peu la
confusion qui règne aujourd'hui quant au
projet du gouvernement et à la manière
dont ils sont débattues au parlement
non mais on courtois il ya une volonté
des coups de dialogues d'entente et les
décisions qui ont été prises sur des
sujets qui sont très importants
notamment dans le secteur éducatif
montre qu'il n'y a pas de volonté de
passage en force qu'il ya au contraire
le souci de la patience et et de
l'écouter dans une démocratie moderne ça
me semble plutôt à être la bonne méthode
oui c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on voit
quand on regarde les lycéens qui
manifestent dans la rue
lorsqu'on entend que xavier darcos
justement reproche au parti socialiste
d'attiser un petit peu le mouvement
lorsqu'on voit vos difficultés sur le
commerce du dimanche non et je vais me
répéter comme ça ça démontrera que je me
contredis pas non que je pense
sincèrement que dans une démocratie
moderne
il faut toujours privilégier le dialogue
donc la méthode qui a été retenue les
explications fournies par xavier darcos
des explications avancées pour le
travail du dimanche par xavier bertrand
montre qu'il y a le temps de la
réflexion et ce temps de la réflexion
et c'est utile cela démontre encore une
fois que nous voulons une démocratie qui
soit une démocratie vivante dans lequel
ce n'est pas toujours les passages aux
forces alors en même temps on entend y
compris d'ailleurs le président de la
république reproché à l'opposition de
faire de l'obstruction
alors ouais mais c'est vrai quelle
espèce de bataille d'amendements et dans
un certain nombre de cas des invectives
qui sont pas dignes précisément de la
démocratie que nous voulons du mode de
fonctionnement de nos institutions
démocratiques jean françois copé a par
exemple eu totalement raison
et de dénoncer l'attitude et cette nuit
wade compte qu'un député failli en venir
aux mains avec un autre ça c'est du
temps révolu ça c'est pas comme ça qu'on
doit fonctionner qu on doit avancer donc
cette sérénité qui est appelé par de
leurs voeux par les responsables de la
majorité répond j'en suis sûr à ce
qu'attendent nos compatriotes ils
veulent pas d'un victimes
ils veulent de vrais débats est ce que
c'est une raison pour mettre en place ce
que certains parlementaires estiment
être une restriction du droit
d'amendement dans le cadre des
discussions actuelles sur l'application
de la réforme constitutionnelle bon
écoutez moi ça concerne pas des textes
que qui sont les miens à la aujourd'hui
donc vous m'interrogez je réponds à la
question qui est posée concernant
l'activité du sénat voilà alors sur la
question de l'immigration vous avez été
interpellé aujourd'hui par le sénateur
jean desessard
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que au
terme de six mois de présidence
européenne on a pu vraiment dépassionner
cette ce dossier à l'évidence oui
puisque le pacte européen que la france
a imaginé mais qui est ensuite portée
par les autres pays de la communauté
européenne
comme vous savez ce pacte sur
l'immigration et l'asile a été adopté et
adoptée à l'unanimité par l'ensemble des
pays c'est à dire quelle que soit la
situation géographique quelle que soit
la sensibilité politique c'est ce que je
rappelle régulièrement aussi bien
l'assemblée qu'au sénat c'est que vous
avez ce pacte sur l'immigration était
encouragée porter voter adoptée par des
ministres communistes
c'est en l'occurrence chypriote par des
gouvernants socialiste en espagne de
travailliste britannique
et puis par des gouvernements de centre
droit comme la france jusqu'au
gouvernement de silvio berlusconi donc
ça signifie que l'europe est capable de
surmonter les clivages idéologiques pour
pouvoir répondre concrètement aux défis
de société parce que la question
migratoire n'est pas un problème ce qui
est un problème c'est l'absence de
politique est donc là nous avançons
concrètement pour répondre à ce défi
on entend aujourd'hui on commence à
entendre la centaine de chefs d'état et
de gouvernement africains dire que alors
qu'elle avait été plutôt épargné jusqu'à
présent
l'afrique commence à connaître les
conséquences de la crise qui s'est
déclenchée aux états unis et qui s'est
propagée ailleurs depuis le début de
l'année est-ce que vous pensez que ça va
avoir justement des conséquences sur les
flux migratoires et qu'il va pas falloir
se pencher là dessus oui il ya d'abord
une réalité c'est que l'afrique a été
jusqu'à présent moins touchés parce
qu'elle est pour l'essentiel à l'écart
des grands circuits financiers mondiaux
et c'est généralement un inconvénient là
il y a un avantage ponctuelles il n'en
demeure pas moins que nous devons faire
attention parce que dès lors qu'il y
avait plus d'essence du chômage ça
signifie que les populations les plus
vulnérables sont les premières touchées
et nous donnons qu'est vigilant
concernant la situation de la population
immigrée dégâts le taux de chômage de la
population immigrée légal est
aujourd'hui de 22 % ce qui est donc à
comparer aux 8 % la communauté nationale
donc il ya un effort à accomplir pour
répondre à la fois aux demandes mais
aussi aux besoins de notre économie
dernière question est ce que vous pensez
dans ce qui a été annoncé hier par le
président de la république avec la
nomination d'un commissaire chargé de la
diversité qui les a des aspects qui sont
je dirais en interaction avec vos
préoccupations ministériel bien sûr j'ai
été d'ailleurs aux côtés du président
lorsqu'il s'est rendu à palaiseau hier
pour écouter son intervention qui a été
extraordinairement riche et positive
c'était pas une situation à l'opération
une situation pleurnicharde c'était au
contraire un message d'optimisme et de
volontarisme qui a été partagée par le
président développé par le président
avec des mesures avec la nomination d'un
commissaire qui souligne parcours
d'ailleurs exemplaire un réussi et de
monsieur sabeg est donc ça rejoint mes
préoccupations est d'ailleurs la
conférence que nous avons organisée à
vichy dans le cas de la présidence
française portait précisément sur
l'intégration et nous avons d'ailleurs à
ce moment là
proposer une boîte à outils avec un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui
d'ailleurs sont totalement validé par
les français puisque l'institut ipsos a
procédé à une étude est de 57 selon les
mesures 1 à 80 % des personnes sondées
en tout cas approuve ces initiatives
donc il ya une attente et nous sommes en
train d'y répondre
merci monsieur ministre d'être venu en
direct au micro de public sénat
perrine tarneaud avec le sénateur de
paris philippe dominati
oui philippe dominati merci d'être avec
nous en direct à ce micro on sent pas
mal d'effervescence aujourd'hui au sénat
beaucoup d'apartés entre les ministres
beaucoup un peu d'énervement je dirai au
sein de la majorité c'est quoi c'est dû
c'est la fin de l'année la fatigue comme
l'année chez un recadrage qui est
naturel à quelques jours de la fin du
débat parlementaire c'est tout à fait
logique
mais quand vous dites recadrage
recadrage de qui de la majorité à landry
y est on a un calendrier extrêmement
chargé entre le gouvernement et le
parlement
on n'a pas eu le temps sans doute de
peaufiner suffisamment un certain nombre
de textes et donc c'est tout à fait
naturel d'ailleurs sa santé dans les
questions d'actualité esquissant aussi
notamment dans l'hémicycle du sénat mais
aussi de l'assemblée nationale avec
l'examen de la proposition de loi sur le
travail dominical tout la réforme autour
de l'audiovisuel public des textes dont
va hériter à la rentrée le sénat comment
votre avis vont se passer les débats ici
sereinement comme d'habitude on va
corriger peut-être quelques
quelques dérives provoquées par les
textes et l'actualité lesquels quelles
dérives on pense à quoi par exemple en
ce qu'il y a des choses à corriger sur
le financement l'audiovisuel très
clairement manifestement bon il est une
polémique à l'assemblée nationale sur
l'audiovisuel il ya des choses qui pour
l'instant peuvent être encore améliorés
très probablement sur le travail
dominical même chose le travail le
dimanche ou même chose mais là aussi de
l'assemblée nationale va prendre son
temps c'est les changements dont vous
parliez qui se sont produits dans la
journée je crois dans l'ordre du jour et
en plus c'est dans la tradition du
chesnay le travail dominical qui ne sera
examinée maintenant la suite du texte
sera examiné par l'assemblée nationale
qu'à la rentrée
voilà sûr on dit que sur la réforme du
projet de loi du ca la réforme de
l'audiovisuel public par dont il n'y a
pas de majorité pour l'instant au sénat
les centristes sont basses et hostile au
texte
écoutez moi je ne connais pas ces de
l'autorité des présidents de groupe
c'est très difficile de savoir s'il ya
une majorité ou pas ce qu'il ya de
certain c'est qu'on sent que ce texte
perturbe dans la majorité même un grand
nombre de sénateurs ça c'est une réalité
ces produits régulièrement dès que le
groupe a été amené à parler de ce sujet
et effectivement il ya encore des
questions non résolues
je pense qu'elles vont resurgir elles
peuvent ressurgir ce qu'il faut toucher
au calendrier des réformes ou continuer
à ce rythme là il faut continuer à ce
rythme et même accélérer
c'est normal qu'il y ait des tensions
parce que le rythme est rapide
les réformes sont nécessaires elles sont
importantes de grande amplitude et
malheureusement il faut encore en faire
plus alors c'est pas toujours simple
parce que ça pas été dans le passé le
même rythme avec la même volonté et
lorsqu'on on fait du mouvement ont fait
un peu de cash ici ou là et on n'est pas
obligé de réussir au premier coup donc
il faut continuer avait à voir ce
calendrier charge parlementaire très
très changé oui oui d'abord il est
stimulant
deuxièmement ils nous obligent à réagir
parce que l'opinion publique réagit et
on est obligé véritablement de réagir et
de de vraiment bien travaillé la loi
donc sur ce plan là moi je suis pas un
rythme soutenu a bien m'écouter merci
beaucoup feu le philippe dominati
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
voilà bah écoutez c'est aujourd'hui la
fin de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et on
se retrouve le jeudi 8 janvier à partir
de 15 heures pour une prochaine séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
très bonne après midi à tous sur la
chaîne parlementaire
ans